we cannot speak with you there's the
soldiers there soldiers yes what are
they doing here we are prison here
what's happening they are keep keeping
here and soldiers is upstairs we cannot
move we cannot speak with you you can't
leave the house they told you that yes I
can't breathe how long are they going to
stay I don't know are they paying you
any money you are kidding he told us
when the soldiers come they wake
everybody up and heard the into a
kitchen for hours while soldiers sleep
in their bedrooms greetings of Peace
before I bring out my next guest former
UFC
MMA fight time world champion Jake
Shields let's have a look at
[Music]
this
this is
the I love
you when I was ready to talk about it I
would I was explaining how much respect
I have for the faith of
Islam show the
show Jake shieldy how's it going how you
doing brother I'm doing pretty good it's
good to have you with us here thank you
thank you so um I time world champion
veteran of the UFC yep tell us for our
audience who is not too familiar with
you a little bit about yourself yeah I
fought like I said for um for 20 years
professionally you know won five world's
titles f for the UFC title uh multiple
Grappling Championships as well so that
was my uh entire life completely focused
for 20 years lately been you know just
kind of randomly started tweeting
started blowing up there so starting to
get a a big following in politics by
accident as well mhm so now you know
doing multiple things you know know what
interesting was that you fought
sakuraba um Sakurai I fought massive
star yeah yeah when when I was listening
to you speak so he was he was a big name
yeah and then you were just coming up
yeah and you beat him yeah saying CU
they asked was one my meaningful fights
that's not one that hardly any people
really remember but that for me that was
meaningful cuz I was completely unknown
they brought me to Japan they gave me
two weeks notice they would give you
short notice cuz they wanted you to lose
no time to do a camp when I went out
there and pulled a massive upset beat
the guy he was ranked number two in the
world at the time and I was unranked so
that was uh pretty cool the first time
on a plane flying out to Japan another
country a massive Arena and pulling a
huge upset so you were M you were mainly
you with other organizations or mainly
with UFC man I was all over the UFC I
was with Strike Force for a while they
were uh Unfortunately they went under
but they were a massive show on Showtime
and uh in CBS they were UFC's big
competitor for a while so I was with
them UFC fought in Japan uh and like
shudo pancreas used to be massive
unfortunately you know the fighting in
Japan's gotten smaller too but they had
massive uh it was bigger than the us at
the time how did you become now so you
you went from fighting and then being a
a veteran here in someone in the UFC and
and in the sport and you become someone
who I've been following for a while on
the Twitter former Twitter X yeah and
you've been you've been um I actually
got this video that I just uh shared
from from page the video that we just
opened up the
program and what's your reaction to uh
some of the words for the people that
have weren't able to um see everything
is pretty much Israeli children singing
we will annihilate everyone in Gaza
Autumn night falls over the beach of
Gaza planes are bombing destruction
destruction look the IDF is crossing the
line to annihilate the SW that swastika
bearers in another year they'll be be
nothing there and we will safely return
to our homes within a year we will
annihilate everyone and we will return
to plow the field at this point I think
it's not really surprising it's kind of
what uh after what we've seen the last
you know uh six weeks or so it's what
you know you see the the genocidal
rhetoric that is not surprising at all
it's still disgusting of course but
we've seen so much of this the last you
know six weeks it's not surprising to me
I think a lot of people at this point
are kind of getting used to still a
little weird to have little kids you
know you know singing a song about
massacring a race of people but not
surprising I remember when this whole
thing started and kicked off one of your
first tweets regarding it you were kind
of on the fence yeah I mean I knew the
Palestinians were you know mistreated
and stuff but also you know that they
pushed the massacre it's such a horrible
thing I can't condone that so I'm like
hey I'm just kind of staying out of this
I understand uh you know I understand
they're mistreated but that was not not
okay what they did but you know the more
the bombing and the more stuff the more
investigating I started doing the more
awful as how Israel was especially now
we were just talking about how the whole
Invasion story is looking not quite what
they originally pushed out like you know
they had warning it was coming they uh
now it just leaked out that Israel was
bombing they killed at least 400 of
their own people Hamas the stories of
the you know the be had of children's
obviously fake no evidence of any rapes
taking they put all a they spun a
extremely fake narrative right away to
freak people out and now that the truth
coming out that's quite different mhm
Max uh Blumenthal he actually he's an
investigated journalist
award winning independent journalists
you know do you know Max Lum I know that
name I've seen his tweets on Twitter I'm
not sure if I follow him or he just pops
up in my timeline yeah he he's actually
someone who's written on this and then
you also have Herz uh I think it's the
Israeli magazine they re they released
uh they adjusted the numbers now but so
what you're talking about specifically
is that I think this what they're coming
out the report I read is uh I've seen
this a couple places now and it seems
like I think the Israeli government even
admits it they come out their uh paty
helicopter paty helicopter that's I saw
yeah yeah yeah the Pache helicopters
they just started blasting people and
they killed you know hundreds of their
own people because they couldn't tell
which was which instead of like waiting
they just started spraying everyone and
I think that's a lot of the probably a
lot of the civilians that died from the
concert was from the Israeli military
yeah and then people getting burned up
and stuff from the he Heavy Artillery
shells from the tanks also yeah you can
see all these like cars in these videos
that people like burnt to death in them
and I don't think I don't know for a
fact but I don't think OS has any
Weaponry to do that
so that that early on was a suspicion of
M when you seeing this row of cars just
totally wiped out it's like well what
what did Hamas allegedly do that with
that was kind of an early sign that
maybe it was something else like
helicopters that came in and done it now
it's uh now that are milon helicopters
came in and wiped them out yeah I just
want to make a disclaimer I I'm not I I
I'm pretty sure you're not I'm not a
card caring member of any hummus or no
definitely not everyone's calling me a
terror sympathizer and you know I'm not
supporting them by any means but I'm
about truth justice and it seems like
that's what you're about yeah I'm just
trying to get to the truth you know I
don't support any terrorist organization
killing any civilians but I prefer to
find out what you know what's really
happening and at the same time I'm not
somebody I'm sure you're not either so
I'm a critical thinker someone who is
not blindly following the mainstream
media yeah I have a mind of my own I
want to investigate and it seems like
you're the same way yeah I know I've
been like I said I just start you know
I've been digging and the more I dig the
more I see uh just lies upon lies that
Israel has been been saying for the
years mhm and that uh they've done a
good job completely controlling media
and they're kind of losing control with
with Twitter and I think I'm not really
on Tik Tok but I guess Tik Tok too so
now they pulled all um all most of the
big advertisers canceled on Twitter
trying to get Elon mus to censor us
because they're calling to censor like
me and some other big accounts that are
uh that you know I'm just I'm just
posting out videos I see pushing
articles stuff like that things that are
true and they're trying to cancel me
usually they're not trying to cancel you
for telling lies it's for spreading
truth mhm you actually sent uh a
respondant to a tweet tweet uh that Elon
Musk he he recently he tweeted he said
um he said this past week so this is
Elon Musk saying this past week there
were hundreds of bogus media stories
claiming that I'm anti-semitic nothing
could be further from the truth and then
uh you responded the word anti-semitic
is completely meaningless and at this
point it's not even worth addressing
when someone makes that accus so this is
you responding to that to so you're
sending uh yeah just sending a message
to Elon I've been called anti-semitic so
many times this week that is a joke the
first couple times I would respond and
you know try to argue with or not but
then you realize it's it's is a
meaningless attack to try to uh to try
to shut you down and of course the
campaign starts and before you know it
the guy's
labeled and he's an anti-em because
that's what we say he is and that's one
stain you cannot
wash now it shames me as a Jew to tell
you that but that's the fact and it's
wrong you know but I have plenty do work
luckily my Jewish friends aren't these
whiny little I see guys trying to get
people fired and canceled my Jewish
friends are still my good friends I've
had no falling out to them over this I
can have a disagreements I'm actually
out here in Chicago you know doing
business with one of my Jewish friends
is the funny part and there's no so so I
people need to make sure not to like
turn the I've I've seen people start
turning racist coures don't it's not
it's not Jews it's the Israeli
government people need to be very clear
about that it's like you know people are
trying to blame Muslims for 911 that's
completely wrong they need to do the
same with this you can't blame all Jews
for what the zionists are doing over
there that's important because uh same
thing with my Israeli and Jewish friends
that I've had on the program and they're
totally against what's happening so
Jewish rabbis Orthodox Jewish rabbis
they're saying that the followers of
Theodore Herzel who made this whole
movement Zionism that's who they're
they're not following Moses the
teachings of true Judaism they're
following this whole Zionist movement
yeah and they're against that also
exactly and that's they're saying not in
our name you have many Jews saying not
in our name exactly it's not it's not
the Jewish faith that's doing this
exactly it was the Zionism the theator
with it Herz or whatever and that's
that's just barely over 100 years old
yeah so I think this is real important
and uh usually what I tell people is me
as a Muslim I love Jesus I love Moses I
love jesus' Mother Mary they were of
that e um that ethnic group so it's
actually it's against Islam to be
anti-Semitic or to hate someone because
they're a certain ethnicity so that do
exactly and I think it's you know all
racism is bad and between and going
against all the religions like all three
of the religions are so similar that's
why I think it's stupid when you see
Christianity Muslim or Judaism fighting
when it's all based off that they all
worship the same God you know what's
interesting over there in Palestine you
have Palestinians who are Christian also
and they're being
oppressed yeah in this situation same
thing they're they're being displaced
same thing and many people don't they
they don't um see that other side and I
really recommend people to go to your
Twitter or ex handle now because you're
one of the leading you where are you R
you're actually one of the leading
people out there now yeah I think pretty
pretty wild I think it's like I'm think
I'm like top 10 in the world in politics
which is top 10 and you you weren't
planning that I had no idea I'm not a
it's funny part cuz I'm not like a don't
consider myself a political commentator
I just you know kind of uh tweet ROM
thoughts in my head but I think it's uh
I think it's just cuz the other people
are so fake I don't think maybe real
that probably shouldn't be in the top 10
but people I'm against are just so fake
they're bot I think it becomes obvious
to people they get sick of it yeah so I
always tweet my real thoughts not
necessarily the most politically correct
I'll just you know tweet random things
without any thought to it you know wake
up send four or five tweets and a lot of
times they'll end up going viral versus
these other guys are all trying to be
think things through try to write them
perfect they have like media teams what
they've done their whole life it's just
so obviously fake and unauthentic and
they also a lot of these guys show their
bot especially this Israel thing a lot
of these guys holding their tongue and
then you start seeing who who funds them
you know guys like Charlie Kirk you know
I asked him one of his tweets uh you
know are you funded by any uh Israeli
Jewish groups you responded I I don't
take money from the Israeli government
and go that wasn't my question then no
no no reply you knowuh you know what I
commend you I mean you have a lot of
people who are courageous enough to uh
jump in a cage to fight you know you've
been doing for so long but when it comes
to standing for something something
important you know something as vital as
this I mean you got innocent babies
lives being how many now it's almost
like 5,000 innocent kids I think it's
more than that now it's more huh and
that's not even Jake that's not even
considering how many are not found under
the rubble yeah so probably yeah
probably a couple thousand more exactly
right did you see those you've saw all
these I mean you know what what touch me
you see these kids who survive but then
the little kids like get my there was
two there was there was um one I won't
forget it was amazing you know just like
how they're pulling together and the
young brother he's like get my brother
over there he's with his sister he's
like get my brother and then the little
one the the little brother he can't be
like five or six he's like where's my
mother where's my mother so they
survived but mother didn't survive
father didn't survive yeah I know it's
so sad you know I'm on some of those
telegram channels and gets the point
where I can't watch too many of them
because it's just sad you know these
kids or parents losing their children
just video after video just you see the
you see the real suffering going on over
there and for me you know when I first
you know first this issue when I first
started sighting with the Palestinian
people my audience was more right-wing
and they were super mad trying to get me
this go to the other side but I'll
always speak what I believe to be true
you know I don't care if I lose
followers think initially I lost around
20,000 followers but you know now now
I've gained more I'd rather speak my
mind and lose followers than be fake to
keep followers yeah and that's that's
what I'm talking about is like people
will now when it comes to standing for
something like what you're standing for
people are scared they're scared to get
cancelled they're scared and that's the
real Courage the courage that you're
displaying now yeah to be fair you know
I do uh have a job where I'm a little
more harder to fire I do have them after
me trying to cancel me from everything I
do uh you know set up to seminar tours
they were sending people letters trying
to get them to cancel trying to get them
all the guys I work with sending letters
trying to make up false allocations of
you know anti-Semitism saying ma Jew
hating Nazi so they they do have
organized groups to try to get people
fired so that's that's how they've been
able to keep that's how they're able to
spread to keep truth from spreading to
keep intimidation
tactic you know you're following the
footsteps of someone like because many
fighters they'll come and go and they'll
be forgotten but people like you know
it's not just because Muhammad Ali he
was a great fighter but it's what he did
outside the ring yeah he stood for
something and he left the Legacy and and
this is you're you're following down the
same way because you're speaking up and
you're using your platform to speak for
justice it's not about being I don't say
Pro this or Pro that it's about Pro
truth pro- justice yeah know I'll always
try to find where I think is truth you
know I'm not going to go and jump
whatever side I think is popular at the
time and yeah I said with my following I
went decid they didn't want me to but
now you know but now I've get you said
you gain you gain new followers you lose
some of the old ones but I'm going to
say what I you know people don't don't
like me for what I'm saying I don't I
don't want them to follow me now I'm
going to take us to this next clip and I
want you to check it out and it's more
so also for the people who are on the
outside and maybe they haven't had much
exposure I just want them to put
theirselves in this person's shoes just
imagine this happening to you and this
is a day-to-day occurrence for many for
people who are living in this side of
the world we understand that Israeli
soldiers came in this morning and
without any notice without any
invitation came into the apartment and
have been there ever
since we cannot speak with you there's a
soldiers there soldiers yes what are
they doing here we are prison here
what's happening they are keep keeping
here and soldiers upstairs we cannot
move we cannot speak with you you can't
leave the house they told you that yes I
can't breathe how long are they going to
stay I don't know are they paying you
any money you are kidding I'm kidding
Abdul naif the bank manager said he had
to get to his bank to open the safe but
that soldiers won't let him go he told
us when the soldiers come they wake
everybody up and her them into a kitchen
for hours while soldiers sleep in their
bedrooms they can't leave or use the
phone or let us in he sent us downstairs
to see if his brother would open the
door so we could ask the soldiers why
they keep taking over this house you
want to come
yes just open the door and
then they close the soldiers close the
door from the
keys they they take the keys so we left
and that night so did the soldiers but
when we returned 2 Days Later the
soldiers were back for more surveillance
this time they kept the women under
house arrest but let the men go to work
and the children go to school when the
children returned we caught a glimpse of
two armed soldiers at the top of the
stairs then more children came
home but the soldiers wouldn't open the
door again they say if you don't go back
behind the wall their children will not
enter the house but this is where the
children live yeah but you need to go
away from the door so I can let the
children come in okay who are
you he's a commander here he's a
commander here yeah can we talk to you
no well we talking to you now why don't
you tell us what you're doing
here have you lost your
voice well they've closed the door now
they've closed the window so I guess um
if the children are going to get get
home we have to um we have to leave so
that's what we'll
do an army spokesman told us the
soldiers use the nazif's house for
important surveillance operations the
naifs told us the soldiers usually stay
for a day or two always coming and going
in the middle of the night when they do
go the NS never know when they'll be
occupied again it could be tomorrow next
week or next month the only certainty
they say is that the soldiers will be
back yeah I think that's it's like crazy
I think it's one of those things to me
I'm not surprised now I think a lot of
Americans don't know this is like the
Norm Norm over there and they'll even
kick people out of their homes for good
it just just goes on they just the way
they treat them think you start seeing
this stuff like this can't be real I
think people are just like refusing to
believe they're doing that but that's
but that's the norm it's like cognant
dissonance like they can't imagine but
do you see like imagine they're coming
he was like there I can't breathe it's
almost like is this a joke is this like
uh you know satirical what no this is
actually his yeah I believe it's a third
amendment in our constitution is so
soldiers can't come in your house like
that so you know you get these that's
why I'm laughing these right-wing
American guys or constitutions they
claim they're defending this it's like
uh you're the same guy saying you use
your Second Amendment right to shoot
anyone that comes in your home and
you're defending these terrorists coming
in kicking people out of their homes
bulldozing their homes it's uh it's kind
of laughable these guys the hypocrisy of
their uh own thinking wow that's a good
point look at that so you you'll fight
here for the Constitution that now Third
Amendment Third Amendment the soldiers
can't come in and uh and use your house
like that cuz that was a problem that
used to happen hundreds years ago where
soldiers come in and take people's homes
they literally wrote it in our
Constitution and these same guys they
say their constitutionalists are
defending Israel also the Second
Amendment we can bear arms we can shoot
people that come in our homes uhhuh yeah
so and he's not just they're not they're
coming in the home sleeping in his bed
imagine someone sleeping in your bed
yeah exactly just like comfor air at
anytime they don't even know I've seen
also some your your post you have so
these are even they have uh what is it
breaking the silence these are former
IDF solders they're coming out and we're
getting stuff from them also yeah I seen
some stories from the IDF saying how
they were that's they were told to do
they' Patrol these neighborhoods they'
tell them to come in at night harass
families wake them up steal the homes is
talking about uh you know what a joke
their job is and this I believe this is
the West Bank I believe which Hamas
doesn't uh operate there so everyone's
like oh it's hamas's fault hamas's fault
well Hamas isn't even in the West Bank
so how do they justify that that's a
good point too that's another side over
here that they're not even there yeah
exactly there's no there's no rationale
to these people's logic it's just been
uh it's been spun by the media so well
it's it's they can't stop believing it
and I think uh I think like most of my
Jewish friends the ones that are you
know hardcore is EUR supporters they
don't believe this stuff either it's not
they think this stuff's right they just
they don't believe it's going on they've
been brainwashed as well and that's
another good point the brainwashing is
also happening now the programming and
hopefully if anyone's sincere and they
take a look because that's what many
people did you know who got on the side
of the truth is they got beyond the
programming and they took a deeper dive
yeah Israel offers like what Birthright
where they pay for all the Jewish people
to come out there they show them around
they preach all this propaganda to them
so they try to put this program in their
heads a lot of them are believe it they
don't you know they don't they don't
know this is going on themselves is that
um the actor James Wood actor James Wood
is he is that actually his Twitter feed
that's he's a famous actor right I was
surprised and I saw him tweeting no
ceasefire no com compromise no
forgiveness and hash kill them all I was
very shocked I mean I I've watched some
of his films he's like good actor I was
shocked yeah especially because Elon
Musk said calls for genocide won't be
allowed and what he's talking about that
is I guess uh saying from from what from
The River To The Sea Palestine will be
free they're trying to say that's
genocide which that could mean a lot
because that could mean so many
different things to be free it justes
means youan the Israelis could move but
but the the Israelis try to say that's a
call for genocide which seems a little
ridiculous so I think Elon caved and
said he won't allow that on there but he
allows this she so you can't say from
The River To The Sea Palestine will be
free but you can say kill all
Palestinians I I've asked yeah that's
ironic I've asked palestin what does
actually mean what are you trying to
eradicate say no I mean you've had as
you know and when I speak to uh people
who know the history this these are
academics they'll say that Jews and
Christians and Muslims for over a
thousand years were living there in
peace till Zionism came about Jews
flourished as as distinctly religious
Jewish communities and they weren't
massacred on the contrary they went to
these Arab and Muslim lands to escape
persecution uh from the Crusades from
the Inquisition and from many other
trials and tribulations and the um and
even World War II uh the Arab and Muslim
lands opened their hearts opened their
lands and uh provided a safe haven and a
gracious Hospitality for the Jewish
people clearly they we we have different
religion and yet uh we were we were
accepted in these Muslim and Arab lands
we believe in one God God and we were
accepted we have different ways of
serving God but yet as I we were
respected and the even the Muslim
religion requires of that of of the uh
the Muslim people to to provide
protection and hospitality and they did
uh carry that out that's clear nobody
could refute this fact the Jews and
Muslims lived in peace for over a
thousand years and why is it suddenly
now that the Muslims these guys
allegedly hate Jews and and suddenly
want to kill them clearly it's Zionism
that's the problem it's not Islam and
it's not Muslims against Jews that's the
main thing we have to tell people it's a
political thing it's Israel it's not the
Jews they were relatively living in
peace and you had now this um movement
that came and you had the aarz state now
it's an aarz State open concentration
camp so when they say River to the Sea
they want to be free of all this just
want their rights that's all it is and
now they're they're banning they're
making it illegal to say that in
multiple countries I think Twitter just
banned that saying I think it's a I
think it's France and Germany made it
where they can arrest you for saying
that and put you in prison it's it's
kind of wild isn't that wild yeah in
France you can't have protests or really
shows you how much power the Israeli
Lobby has you know that's thing I wasn't
aware of either you see like how every
politician the guys that were claiming
they were anti-war they all of a sudden
jumped at War for Israel then I started
saying this makes no sense I started
digging you know APAC by by far the
strongest uh Lobby in the United States
which is uh APAC the pro Israel Lobby
which all other foreign lobbies have to
register as a foreign agent but for some
reason APAC doesn't so they're able to
raise massive amounts of money which can
be hard to track for these politicians I
think they're bragging what they think
get like 97% of the candidates they pick
when their elections so they're pretty
much rigging us elections so they can
control our our political system wow
MH and no one will ban it because they
control them all so they're not going to
pass law making it illegal to to lobby
as it should be cuz they have all the
politicians in there mhm so they've
created such a mess it's going to take a
while to un to unwind it but at least
people are starting to wake up and
starting to see it mhm what do you think
uh recently you had um you had Candace
Owens she had a tweet and it was a
pretty and I commend her really she had
a a tweet that started off with saying
blessed are the
peacemakers and then she went on with
the rest of it and it was uh and then at
the end she said you cannot serve both
God and money mhm and then there was
this back and forth with her and and Ben
Shapiro did you see that uh clip with uh
with Ben Shapiro I saw them arguing a
little bit but let me show you the clip
and I'll get your your com the question
is back cand I think her behavior during
this
[Applause]
disra
yeah she still works my company I think
she's been absolutely disgraceful I
think I think that her her fo
sophistication on these particular
issues has been ridiculous it's not CL
sophistication it's ridiculous everybody
can see the moves that she's making and
the things that she's saying and I find
disreputable calling for peace he's
calling disgraceful seems ridiculous
because Candace Owens hasn't even said
that much but they just want to
completely control everyone they can see
she's probably starting to lean towards
that side so they're trying to shut her
down so some other organization was like
denouncing her today so
yeah that's all she was doing she was uh
as um as a Christian and I was wondering
like you know how are you going to be
able to support something like that
and now she's actually taking a stand
subtly I mean just you know softly not
even hard and then boom he's like
attacking her and whatnot cuz she's just
calling her heart I mean you can't just
help it like you're these are human
beings but they want to paint everyone
like their animals see and this is the
same thing that that was that was done
to Jews at that time what Hitler was
doing what Nazis were doing painting
them as rats and animals but then it was
like what you yeah know say they're
doing the exact same thing with Benjamin
Netanyahu calling the Palestinians like
human animals and uh it's pretty wild
the exact same things they've always
talk about they're doing yeah and that's
the ironic thing so she came out and
then now he's you know um saying what
he's saying about
her and he seems like he's been really
fueled up he's like
um really excited about
just War you know he's like really
excited about just um how much is enough
to him it doesn't seem like there's
there's a limit yeah it seems like they
want the complete annihilation of you
know of Gaza and probably the West Bank
it doesn't seem like they're really
trying to do any settling they don't
really seem like they want any two State
solution seems like they just want to
wipe them out you know there's been
multiple people like Nikki Haley talking
about oh let's let's bring them into
Europe and America
it it doesn't seem like you know said
they have they have so much control over
our politicians it seem like they want
to wipe them out and get them you know
take take what Le left to Palestine and
take that land do you know a fighter he
he was recently um on The Joe Rogan
podcast Ted Ted Kennedy Tim Kennedy Tim
Kennedy did you ever fight him no I know
I know him but never fought him yeah
what what he he had some comments
recently how did you I didn't watch the
episode I think he's a little more like
pro Israel but I didn't watch the
episode so
yeah so you didn't watch that huh no
yeah um is so you have where do you see
this going where where do you see now
with everything that you know and
everything you're you're becoming more
and more educated where do you see this
going it's hard to say it's you know
it's
uh I don't see any good solution
unfortunately especially for the
Palestinians they're out there getting
massacred their homes are all wiped out
you know tens of thousands I think
around 20,000 of them have been killed
now now uh it's up to 20,000 I think I
saw like 19 written this morning not not
to mention the the missing wow and then
I think it was like more like two I
think 75% of them are homeless now so
what's the solution they have nothing to
rebuild nowhere to go so I don't really
know what they're going to try to do
they're going try to push them out to
Europe and America as refugees are they
going to let them rebuild it's uh I
don't really see Israel offer them
anything I don't unfortunately I don't
see what good solution they can
have it is um you know we we often had
that slogan like never never again and
rightfully so yeah rightfully so you had
the the evil Holocaust that happened and
this is why we kept hearing this
repeated never again to any that's not
just for one people for any people but
now we're seeing it in 4k and it's like
I always I'm saying now like okay never
again but except for this group of
people yeah you know I think they used
Holocaust such an awful thing I think
they use that as leverage to silence
people so it allowed them to be pushing
a genocide and if you mention that they
would mention there they'd be like
Holocaust Holocaust they've done a great
job of weaponizing it because
unfortunately there's been a lot of uh
awful genocides throughout history but
none of the other ones are pushed like
the Holocaust you know there's there's
been multiple cases you know what 100
million people died through communism
but they don't push that so that's their
way of sciencing their critics and I
think they were kind of uh keeping the
secret what they were doing uhhuh so um
do you see now when you talk to a lot of
the um people who are also in in the in
the UFC and other veterans uh does this
topic does it come up because you have a
lot of followers and what's their do you
see more people wanting to speak up or
what's their stance or what's the the
feeling in the MMA World UFC world the
majority of the guys I talk to like
either mostly agree with me or partially
agree a few guys disagree I think uh a
lot of guys just don't want to speak up
which I understand it's like they're
kind of trying to keep themselves you
know out of politics especially seeing
the power of these some of these groups
have that are on the opposite side all
the power and money is on the opposite
side unfortunately yeah you know truth
on our side but but the power and money
is all no one's getting fired you know
for uh for supporting Israel despite
them doing a genocide but lots of people
are getting fired for supporting
Palestine there's a great saying that if
you you either
stand stand for something or you or you
fall for anything so those that's where
you have you know the the true true men
true people of Courage you know and
that's that's you know what separates uh
the real men from the boys you know the
ones who who really have a heart not
just to get in the cage but to stand up
for things that uh will really make a
difference in the world and you're
trying to speak UPS to help have a
ceasefire to help stop babies kids from
from dying yeah you know it's tough and
sometimes like oh is it worth this
backlash but then you know I get people
all the time uh you know saying I had a
bunch of accounts saying they were on
the fence and they change their mind
from my account and then I get people
thanking me wherever I go people you
know have people even bring me gifts so
I'm like all right I guess it is uh it
is worth put putting myself on the line
you you also had something that someone
can interpret as like a threat on your
life recently also and it was someone
who's I think he's like washed up uh MMA
fighter yeah bum of a fighter I know the
guy he was in New York when I was out
there oh you knew the guy yeah he
wouldn't train with me because he was
terrible he would get beat up by uh
Gordon Ryan's little brother was like 13
the time and he was like tapping him out
with ease way yeah he wouldn't train
with me but then he's uh out riding
missiles names of first he first he
wrote a bunch of the Muslim Fighters
names on missiles and I said that's kind
of ridiculous that he would do that then
he like wrote my name on a missile like
oh I'll send this to you so putting my
name on missiles to go blow up little
kids with it it's uh it's such a weird
thing how they write names of missile or
they write like taunts on missiles and
they'll bring Israeli school children to
go and write like uh to write on
missiles and Logo bomb Palestinian
children's with it it's just such a such
a sick thing they do yeah I saw the the
name with khabib and then you had Hamza
then you had uh Muhammad bow but then
not too long ago you got added on that
list yeah yeah exactly cuz I was
speaking out so he put me it's like yeah
it's like a threat you know I have like
direct uh direct threats in my life too
yeah I think they're mostly you know
full of it but it still sucks when you
open your inbox people saying they're
going to come and kill you and be
because what because you're trying to
have the you're trying to save the
babies yeah they don't I think just they
don't want some of the Truth Exposed I
think Israel only survived through a lie
you know or I think at this point
they've been there long enough or people
would be happy if they did a real
two-state solution but I think they want
to continue taking all the all that land
mhm yeah that's what it seems like it
just uh these things are used as a
pretext to go ahead and just keep
grabbing land just keep grabbing land
yeah and that was uh when you had uh I
don't know if you had a chance I really
recommend people to bringing it back to
caceo and she brought on a person whose
parents survived the Holocaust mother
and father and other family members were
killed in the Holocaust Norman finlin
he's Jewish academic 40 years he
dedicated his life to this and and those
are the people those stories really
fascinate me people of Jewish descent
Israelis historians ID former IDF
breaking the silence who who come out
you posted a lot of these also who'll
come out and they'll speak on the side
of Truth yeah why for why because you
know they have so much to lose but
they're coming out to let the world know
yeah CU they just know they're on the
wrong side you know it takes a lot to
own up but you know maybe especially
your IDF you're fighting on the wrong
side or being Jewish everyone expects
you to be on a certain side because
you're race but uh but truth should
trample that truth should trample that
yes a absolutely before all this uh
started happening we were talking about
there was um things that were going on
and you were discussing you were on top
of these things you had people coming
into the
sports arena and they were taking first
place because they
were they were biologically they were
born as a man but they were coming in
competing as women you were you were
calling that out yeah I think you were
one of the few calling that out that's
utterly absurd and that's that shows the
absurdity of it because this is an issue
that almost everyone agrees with and now
a lot of people are starting to speak
against it but when I first started
speaking against this I was one of the
only people doing it it was like it was
considered Brave like how is it Brave to
speak against men competing with women
everyone can look at that and be like
this is insanity but when I was first
doing it no one would Retreat my stuff
they would like it they they would tell
me in secret like oh I agree with you
but I can't say it it's like what are
you talking about everyone agrees like
you know everyone I talk to oneone would
agree with me but then everyone was
scared to say it so you see things it
shows you a lot of times with truth most
people know it's true but they're scared
to speak it and that one to me was was
the most ridiculous because everyone
knows a man and a woman are not the same
physically and people were just too too
scared to say it because they were told
they're not supposed to it just shows
you how people would just go along with
absurd lies just because they think
they're supposed to yeah and and that's
what
has you stand out from from from the
rest right because you're you're not
somebody who's uh not only scared to uh
come against you know All Odds in the
Octagon or the ring but also in real
life you're you stand for what you
believe and if you go in the direction
of Truth so yeah I'm not willing to
pretend that that a woman is a man as a
man is a woman because I'm told uh
that's what I'm supposed to believe and
I was uh shocked how many people are
going along with that I think now not as
many people are going along with with it
I think people are starting to no one
ever believed it but people were scared
to say it before it was weird that that
was a controversial to say extremely
controversial to say that a year ago but
now people are starting like all right
this is absurd I'm not going along with
it yeah it's crazy anything uh coming up
now how's uh with you anything uh so
you're retired now yeah you know it's
possible to hop in for you know one more
if it was a if it was like a big fight
that made sense you know yeah it's a
bigname guy but I'm not trying to win
any more World titles it's uh when
you're fighting at that world
championship level you got to be laser
focused all you're doing all day just
train train train I'm more on the
business into fighting you know just
finished up uh SAR tour with Adas and I
just kind of uh you know relaxing a
couple more days of uh of work out here
in Chicago then back to Las Vegas
getting the chance to meet Nate Diaz
with you I mean he's a really like down
to earth guy he was uh he was really
cool just a real nice guy he's crossed
into like mainstream celebrity so it's
but it hasn't gone to his head he's
still super down to earth super chill uh
you know still one of my best friends
yeah you you would think like you know
you get someone can get the wrong
impression but just getting a chance to
spend some time with him and you you
just seem like a nice guy yeah exactly
I've been fortunate where I st myself
with good people yeah how can people go
ahead and reach your channel there or
your your page that they can go ahead
and follow up on many of the things that
uh you're sharing and how I got exposed
to a lot of the things through through
through your page actually yeah my
Twitter is uh Jake Shields ajj my
Instagram is just Jake Shields so those
are probably the two best places to
follow me yeah all right thank you thank
you it's good good having you on the
program thanks for having me thank you
Jake God bless you I cannot leave
without giving you a gift if you're not
yet Muslim and you tuning in to see what
these Muslims are talking about and you
like a free copy of the Quran go ahead
and visit theen show.com we'll take care
of the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions about Islam call us at 1
18662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum
brothers and sisters we've
all